die messe landau gefährlich wäre ja
nicht mein t shirt dreckig machen was
steht da drauf aber das ist eigentlich
bin kannst du das eigentlich jedes mal
einfach anziehen ist das geburtsjahr mal
in einem busch überraschung
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut mir auch heute kam
bereits auf seinem youtube kanal das
video im supermarkt personen verfolgen
und alles nachkaufen plus damit kochen
an uns vorbei und wir haben einfach kein
service hinsichtlich hier und hier bin
ich dann zur kasse gefahren die waren
fertig und habe mich halt an die andere
kasse gestellt damit es nicht zu
offensichtlich ist und dort halt einfach
genau das gleiche
um diesen zweiten part lust damit kochen
geht es eigentlich heute also das machen
weil das letzte video war schon über
zehn minuten da habe ich gesagt ja gut
kommen reicht müssen wir nicht nur mit
kochen also an die den ersten paar noch
nicht gesehen haben schaut euch den auf
jeden fall erstmal an und dann schaut ab
hier weiter weil sonst macht das finde
ich nicht so sind wir haben insgesamt
zehn verschiedene artikel zum kochen
gesorgt oder haben die agape kauft wie
diese leute die halt vor uns unterwegs
waren und ich hab mir das ganze
weibliche unterstützung geholt weil ihr
wisst ja ich bin noch nicht so der beste
koch ich gebe natürlich mein bestes ist
und ich möchte mich auch weiter
fortbilden diakon um so endlich bis zu
einem platz wo du hingehörst also leute
das ist lieb und die helfen wir heute du
kannst gut kochen was mir erzählt mir
deswegen ich war ehrlich so mit diesen
ganzen sachen ich habe so eine mädchen
gemüse reis fahne noch nie gemacht
deswegen brauche ich und wir schauen
einfach mal was am ende dabei
herauskommen ich kann hier noch kurz
hier mal die sachen vorstellen wir haben
hier pro kollege kauft jasmin reis dann
haben wir curry märchen paprika hier
also dass sie es hier auch was sagst du
jetzt qualität
roger weise aufgegriffen also das sind
die sache ich würde sagen kann haben wir
fangen an also das hier ist unsere fahne
und hier haben wir ja perfekt also an
alle die aus der comic branche kommen
und vielleicht ein sponsoring haben für
ein paar neue fallen oder so gerne dass
jetzt wieder von meiner lieblings marken
ein
also mir wurde insgesamt muss der lassen
er wurde jetzt gesagt ich soll dir
natürlich entscheiden habe ich vorher
also doch habe ich schon mal gemacht
aber ich bin dass wir sind wirklich so
ja noch einfach mal die helfen übrigens
leute ich kann euch schon mal sagen bald
kommen so eine kleine video reihe mit
einem koch der kocht für die deutsche
nationalmannschaft also der hat wirklich
voll drauf da freue mich schon sehr
schöne grüße an dieser stelle pfizer
siehst und der bringt dir das war ja
versucht deshalb zumindest ich glaube es
ist von der qualität her nicht so gutes
hühnchenfleisch das hier das ist schon
okay ich hab hier super hat dass das
muss auch nicht kleiner sein mal das
wird auch noch kleiner band anbraten
aber ich mag das wenn das so kleine
stücke sind bis zum ersten mal
aufgefallen ich wäre ich mein t shirt
reck gemacht
was steht da drauf aber das eigentlich
bin
kannst du das eigentlich jedes mal
einfach anziehen
die schürze ist das geburt die damals in
einem guss überraschend also ich bin ich
muss sagen so als kleines
zwischenresümee ich bin schon mal
relativ zufrieden das sieht schon mal
professionell haushalt nicht allein
hinbekommen
ich wäre auch gar nicht auf die idee
gekommen mit schneidebrett zu machen so
passt mal auf jetzt habe ich hier
nämlich im kommentar gelesen wieder
haben das video natürlich schon geschaut
und hier wurde jetzt geschrieben wird
selbst vorschlag auf die schnelle preis
abkaufen pärchen in etwas öl anbraten
gehörenden kleinen streifen schneiden
und auf dem mädchen der surenburg und
diakon paprikastreifen und paprika in
streifen und ebenfalls im münchen
beifügen abgekocht dabei ist und
brokkoli mit in die pfanne geben mit der
ama creme verrühren und ordentlich curry
ach ja ein paar zutaten hätten wir noch
nie in ein glas und mit den salami
stücks rühren
salamischeiben falten und ans glas als
deko anbringen also da sage ich jetzt
mal nur eins zu genauso wie der name auf
youtube weiß ich nicht
die heißt weiß ich zu so dass jetzt soll
dann der fahrer jetzt tun wir die
hähnchen stückchen da rein kommt man
ganz auf professionell sehr gut alles
was irgendwie schon wieder ausgemacht
das sieht nicht gut aus bis jetzt mit ja
das ja auch schon so viel
alles klar hätte wofür die
falsch
ich hab's gemacht aber macht das schon
das gab sie schneiden sie sind einfacher
zu machen erstmal das ganze hier auf
beschneiden
die leute bevor ich hier weiter
kritisiert werden wir schon mal den reiz
da habe ich gerade ermittelt dass der
verband offen ist sie haben das habe ich
da jetzt anders gemacht
ich mache das für deine arbeit zu ende
ich jetzt von anfang an ganz anders
gemacht aber sie kann nicht videos
schneiden besser als du okay so jetzt
habe ich hier mit der paprika angefangen
die wie das noch kurz und streifen
geschnitten auch noch kleinere stücke
machen so oder ja ich hab mir da würde
ich schon sagen ja
die paprika let's go kurs alive
wegkommen weil man hat ja sonst mal das
problem dass das daneben fällt deswegen
musste hier willkommen das funktioniert
ja gar nicht dass ich irgendwo gesehen
im internet ihr wollt ich bin anders
weiß live funktioniert gar nicht jetzt
kommen die möbel keine müssen eigentlich
erst mal geschätzt werden aber gut 8000
solcher antraten
ich will auch gar nicht so viele märchen
guck mal hier an sieht man doch dass ich
nicht zum ersten mal machen oder im
landschulheim aber nicht drauf die das
also das hühnchen muss aber noch bist ja
leistungsstufe und und ein bouchacourt
während das kochen war noch ein bisschen
nebenbei ja dann manchmal sorge sollte
wenn dieses video 56 erreicht trage ich
bei jedem koch jetzt immer diese teams
gegen stürze und saatgut umso leichter
als nächstes kommt jetzt für die sahne
so sein
das ist eigentlich auch gleich schon
deutschland da kommt dann auch der reis
dazu
okay das ist eigentlich ein ganz netter
die viel dazu sagen
das kinderlachen glaubt ja
die queen of curry ist immer gut aber es
ist auch mikrofon curry gelandet so der
reis ist jetzt hier drin in der
engelgasse jetzt kommt dagegen das finde
ich mal gespannt ob das klappt
vulkane vulcano lustig zuging war eine
gute idee von mir und das von jetzt hier
oben drauf
schon richtig cool auch wenn es
eigentlich auch jetzt so ist eine große
potsdam okay leute so sieht es aus ich
muss sagen ich bin wirklich zufrieden
das ist bis jetzt das beste essen was
ich selber oder wo ich selber beim
kochen meine finger mit dem spieler ist
auch wirklich gesund also genau ganz
kurzen auch hier wegen diesen salamis
tricks hier mehr rausgelassen kein
fahren warum nicht gekauft haben aber
wir können damit nichts anfangen
deswegen gibt es die gabel
auf jeden fall muss ein bisschen mehr
hinnehmen
ja und es sieben von zehn der bewertung
hätten noch ganz mehr am besten meines
bildes werden kann trägt aber trotzdem
von mir schon mal acht punkte ist uns
gut gemacht na ja leute natürlich auch
sagen also das war's mit dem ersten
professionellen koch wie du von mir wenn
er sagt alex mal auf jeden fall mehr
davon geht man nach oben dann etwas
gutes getan hast du jetzt mal ein
schnaps außen kann
und ja das war's schenkt man uns denn
wir mal ob alex wir jeden tag um 19 uhr
gibt's neues video hat